work on my new video in the d4
repertoire series this video will deal
with one d4 and then they ply on e6
which can be quite tricky to meet it
maybe not play that often but it has got
some interesting points so it's not to
be dismissed lightly um yeah first first
of course you need to mention that white
here has the option of course to to
transpose to French with with to e4 and
well to be honest if you if you have
some experience with one e4 opening so
you have some specific line against the
French that you really like then it's
actually quite a good idea to play this
as it may be from purely theoretical
perspective maybe be the best move as it
might be easier to get something against
the French then against the other lines
after d-46 yeah one interesting point is
that I think the move is six is I think
a really good reply to d4 and I think it
would have been it would be much more
popular if if not for a truly form
because of every black player who
intends to go one is six of course needs
to have something in case white really
transposed to the French so it's I think
one of the reasons why this move is not
more popular on on the top toplin
top-level chess because those guys maybe
don't really like to go for a French and
at that level that might happen much
more often than on amateur
semi-professional level yeah okay but
for repertoire of course I have see
forest may move and now sir
a big parting of the ways of course one
is six doesn't really define a specific
line this is done here on move to yep
like has a rather big range of
possibilities one move from which is I'm
not quite sure I didn't check the
statistics but just maybe the most
popular since f5 transposing to to
attach defense but I will look at this
in a separate video when we deal with
the Dutch as it might also rise from d4f
five of course so let's get on with the
other options one options I actually
have firm spoken about this in c5 which
supposes to a kind of Benoni and this
move order I actually am handled in the
independent video so so already I'm
covered so I want other moves are them
um yeah one interesting move here is
this should be for check which is a
strange kind of BOGO Indian the bog
Indian usually arises just to show it
quickly and in this position which is
the pure BOGO Indian and here we have a
similar play but without the Knights
played Knight f3 and 906 so the black is
somewhat more flexible in regards to his
F pawn and also his all central
formation um I am had a really yeah
deeper look at this line and my
recommendation here is maybe somewhat
surprising I actually recommend to play
a Bishop d2 here it might look natural
to to play Knight c3 as we
also play the nimzo-indian which would
rise after night at 6:00 but black here
has other options which which are better
I think really better than that f6 the
name is o is fine of course but here
black can actually take the chance and
play moves like b6 f5 or c5 which are
all not easy to meet really especially
b6 as troublesome option I will talk
about this in in a couple of minutes
when we handle to p6 instead of the
check which is another move order
similar just similar him um so um I
recommend Bishop t2 and now on Black has
some options of course he needs to deal
with the bishop somehow I think the the
most-played move here is actually a 5
but let's look at the other ways here
first black might also play 27 to cover
the bishop and then I recommend to play
directly eform
if we would play Knight f3 Knight f6 we
would transpose to the BOGO it's also ok
of course but I think he force a good
idea here to UM use the fact that the
night hasn't moved yet
then black usually plays d5 25g takes d4
Bishop c4 um this is the structure which
is somewhat similar to structure that we
all also get in the Queens gambit
accepted where DNC pawn I exchanged and
white plays d4 and that move for
instance 30 for the Queens gambit
accepted Knight f6 and then II 5 that is
rather similar
why does somewhat better he had due to
his space advantage and the somewhat
problematic bishop on c8 it's not great
Vantage but it's it's a nice to play um
and black also has got the options here
to take on d2 which is a very solid line
I then recommend our Queen d2 yes I
think it's just better than 92 the night
is not very actively placed on d2 then
black mostly plays Knight f6 and then I
suggest to to fianchetto here and just
play this position I think it's also not
advisable to spend I don't know how us
about these subscibe subtle points here
because it is not played that often what
is good to know here though is if you
don't play g3 and go along here with the
simple development for instance
something like this this is very fine
for black for instance rook c1j X takes
rook the eight and then c5 later this is
very toothless I think it's almost
almost equal here the structure is
somewhat similar to to the last comer
Nuva and the Queens gambit declined but
the bishops I exchanged but here somehow
White Queen is also not so well on you
too and black has got c5 coming this is
just nothing so I think what should
really influence at OPM um okay the main
main move here is a five if I have to
cover the bishop and then I suggest to
go Knight c3 which is I think a good
idea the main alternative is Knight f3
or g3 which you can also look at but 93
I think is yeah I think the most
powerful move the ideas just play you
for in the next move for instance of
black plays Knight f6 here you can
really play for because of the of the
trick let's have a quick look if black
takes here you have twin g4 which is
nice for white one point being that if
black captures here now
you can you can just take on g7 of
course because the rock is hanging and
white is clearly better better would be
something like d5 but in such a position
on what should also have some some
advantage um instead of from Knight f6
black of course it's got other moose for
instance g6 you could you just play you
form the five and then a through takes
it takes on c3 Knight f6 and White has
got a nice central position okay
black might also play f5 on the fourth
move to mix some Dutch themes in your
white also can play d4 and here it is
not even a gambit or any trick involved
you could just play this year but also
Queens before a song is interesting
again attacking g7 all in all and this
looks pretty decent for white okay this
was some I think it should be for check
and essential um another and very tricky
line is b6 and this also sometimes
called the English on defense because
some it was made popular by a couple of
English players like Tony miles and John
Spearman here it is very important that
white chooses carefully because some
rather natural looking moves might lead
to early problems I'll show one
variation which is very essential to
understand that you need to avoid it
let's say we play a form we should be
seven
and here at this point 93 I actually
think that this is already somewhat
imprecise to play the smooth after
Bishop before and it's actually
difficult to properly defend the center
or to avoid a complete mess of course if
you into messy positions you might find
something here but it is that is really
problematic if I was just hanging and if
you cover it with the natural move from
Bishop b3 black immediately can push at
five and this is tricky because the
capture here can really be answered with
this move as Queen h5 check which is
often a problem of f5 can be just
answered with King f8 and black will
just win the rook in the corner for
nothing um so one after f5 you need to
already play uh natural moves somewhat
like we need to or something to and to
cover this pawn and to make it short
this variation is simply nothing for
white another typical move here would be
F 3 which would be also similar to the
line we play against the nihms oh so it
would make sense but here black can lash
out with f5 immediately and this is
really a problem let's say you take here
and then the strange-looking move Knight
h6 is coming with the point that if you
capture it Queen h4 will pick up the
bishop here and white will will have
huge problems on the dark squares and so
usually white white shakes here and then
not f4 f you see it as a total mess so
this variation I simply won't recommend
because black has got all the fun so we
need to get back here
and think again actually I would like to
recommend to lie
yeah my mainland was a c4 I think this
is just the best one but that's an
alternative I also like to mention the
the move a 3 here which prevents Bishop
before once and for all and the mainline
there runs which should be 793 f5 d5
Knight f6 g3 and so on this is a line to
recommend form for players who would
like to keep the game a little bit more
in the strategic fashion and want to y2
to learn the rather sharp lines that
arise after a 4 because 34 which is my
main move on really requires some good
nerves and some lines and also some
knowledge there should be 70 and as I
mentioned 93 is not so not so great year
so we should be 3 as my main move um and
now black has more than one move one
which leads to total chaos and others
that lead to a slow play slows TG play
that should be somewhat better for white
let's look at the slow ones like might
attack the d4 pawn here you can you
should cover it 92 is also may be
somewhat more aggressive aggressive than
that f3 because at least you have pawn
open and then usually this kind of
position arises where white should be
somewhat better with the center um an
alternative would be to play Bishop
before someone mixing the ideas of the
two lines here b6 and Bishop b4 check
there you just play Bishop d2 and go for
normal development I think it's a good
idea also here to get the Knight to e2
the ideas later to get this Knight to c3
and the denied the to Knight to f3
maybe also thinking about f4 at some
point what just has more space in the
center so it should be a comfortable
position the real deal here is is at
five and after this move you have no no
choice really you need to capture this
pawn and this of course will get we got
wild the by far the main move here for
black is to give this check on before as
the capture on g2 has a very bad
reputation it is still tricky white
white will get a huge attack but okay
you need to have a good nerves and maybe
it's an idea to to look at this a little
bit before rewrites a whole rakia but
you get lots of protectors check it a
check here black needs to go g6 takes on
g6 and now black has just one move
Bishop g7 not f6 is answered by the
typical trick g7 Shrek Knight X and you
get a new Queen alleged winning the rook
and white is clearly better than just
just winning and actually so Bishop g7
needs to be played
then you capture here King f8 and then
white has more than one interesting
possibility I like to suggest nighty to
here
for instance if black takes now on h1
Bishop g5 9 f6 Queen h4 96 Mady to
follow up a long Castle and Bishop
Knight to f4 White has sacrificed a
whole rook here but it's pretty obvious
that he's got very strong compensation
it's not completely winning or something
if you if you enter this into him and
you're a strong engine
it tells you something like I don't know
zero point something for one side I'm
not sure so it's obviously sees that
white has huge tech and compensation but
it's not completely clear-cut it's of
course really a hard task to defend this
thing but okay you need to be aware of
you if you play Bishop d3 and it's
playing f5 you need to be ready to
sacrifice this rook in the corner so it
might not be everybody's cup of tea but
I think this is a sacrified thing you
should just go for and and play this out
of it doesn't work out what can you do I
think it's objectively white it's very
good here but it's it's risky of course
okay but main move especially for check
as black players of course are not so
keen on defending this disposition and
now the problem is that white of course
would like to somehow um just block the
check with with a piece but this this
actually allows this again we we had a
look at this before as long check can be
answered with the simple King move so um
after Bishop before check one actually
needs to play a king of one to cover g2
and now on black usually just develops
Knight f6 93 castles a3 Bishop d6 Knight
c3 something like this and of course
this is also a pretty unconventional
position White has a huge score here it
doesn't seem to be entirely correct from
next point of view but of course it's
somewhat messy so you also need to be
ready for this kind of position also
what you what you need to take note of
it is better here too to just develop
like like I said like I showed in this
line there are other ideas for in
you could be tempted to play c5 at this
position in order to to block this
Bishop here let's say it takes a three
you should a 5d c5 and then before the
next move but this might be answered
with stuff like just just a quick look
95 before the Queen f6 this gets
completely messy and I'm not sure about
the theoretical state here
Black has won a couple of nice games
with this kind of this kind of stuff so
just get on with developing here and you
should be okay um yeah this was um 6v6
or the English the English defense it's
it's tricky so you need to look look at
some lines I think just pick the ones
that I showed here and maybe look at
this a little bit more detail I think
you you should be should be fine